let's talk about what italy did and then
we'll go into australia as well so sure
let's first do italy this is march 9th
italy slaps facial recognition uh firm
clearview ai with a 20 million dollar
fine uh italy's data privacy watchdog
said it will find the controversial
facial recognition from clear uei for
breaching eu iran investigation by
italy's data protection authority found
that the company's database of 10
billion images of faces
includes those of italians and residents
in italy the new york city-based firm is
being fined 20 million and will also
have to delete any facial biometrics it
holds of italian nationals this isn't
the first time that the
uh beleaguered facial recognition tech
company is
is facing legal consequences the uk uk
data protection authority last november
fined the company 22 million dollars
after finding its practices which
included collecting selfies of people
without their consent from security
camera footages or mock shots violate
the nation's data protection laws the
company also has been banned in sweden
france and australia
that's a lot of countries that are not
happy with you
yeah well you know what's upset you know
but heartbreaking about this stuff is we
had in 2019 some law enforcement
agencies just use a demo of that
software
about software to help solve crimes
against children um and
i think it's a bit of a overreaction
from a lot of detractors when the first
story about clearview ai came out but
our legal team's handling it we got a
great legal team um and we don't do any
business in the eu so
you know there's no
you know jurisdictional argument for
that and again the legal team is
handling it i think
um
they're
overdone um the maximum fine in you know
gdpr should only be four percent of
total total revenues um four percent of
total that's what the law says right and
you know
they've gone um overboard and
um but you know the hard work part isn't
per case no no that's a total max but
anyway my point is again i'm not the
legal team so i shouldn't be talking
about that
my point is
let me ask this question here so just
for my own if my only reason to know
this as a guy that runs businesses is it
four percent
total or four percent italy four percent
australia four percent xyz where you
know 100 countries do it could be 400
percent
yes
i got you yeah okay i got it and under
the gdpr almost every privacy law out
there has exemptions for law enforcement
for government usage for consent based
where you're opting in and and so on so
um yeah the the part that is upsetting
to me a bit is we had people use it to
save children and solve crime there so i
think it's a misunderstanding of how uh
our intentions behind the technology uh
which are about to
you know help do good in the world yeah
but why would these guys have i mean i
get that i don't
so one would have to speculate and say
a country is protecting its child
traffickers i don't think they are okay
are there any out there that do
they have to be the most corrupt
governments out there that are being
paid off yeah but is that countries the
size of
france italy australia i don't think so
i think it would be catastrophic like
australia came out and said facial
recognition from clear video has been
ordered to cease collecting photos of
australians from the internet and it
revealed police
it was revealed to police that some
states had trialed the technology
on wednesday the information privacy
commissioner determined clear vai had
breached the privacy of austrians by
collecting images of them online on
wednesday uh then it says and ordered
the company delete all the images of
people in australia within 90 days and
not collect anymore but clearly ai has
stood its ground saying it operates
legitimately in australia and tends to
appeal its decision
uh ai is a facial recognition service
that claims to build up enormous
databases
okay so you see how some of these and by
the way this was i want to say november
21st around november of 2021 which is
like four or five months ago at the peak
of what was going on in australia okay
where some may even support what you
were doing because the world wanted to
know what the hell is going on in
australia some may say hey i want to
know what's going on australia they give
those guys a little bit of freedom
because there was two sides to it you
have to do this you have to do that you
can't get out if you don't take the shot
you can't get a job so you were playing
the role of a hero so is this a little
bit of these countries
do it themselves but they don't want
somebody else from the outside to do it
is there worry that maybe you are linked
to the us government where this
information is being leaked to them what
would be any of these countries a
concern we have to ask them but uh
because it's hard to read into their
motivations completely but these are
just the privacy agencies of these
countries right so
um they have their own agenda they have
their own belief in privacy and
role that they want to do you know
we hope that
we can engage in the debate and just
help educate because again a lot of
these laws do have exemptions for
governmental use they have exemptions
for national security and um and that's
you know our intention and i don't think
they want to be seen as people enabling
child traffickers these privacy
commissioners in these countries so our
work has been focused on countries who
do need us uh in the u.s has a lot of
need and most recently in ukraine uh
it's been used very successfully you
reached out to them that's a yeah you
will give it to it free of charge to use
it did they accept it did they yeah so
about i think maybe two or three weeks
ago
as a company we're seeing all the
horrific stuff that came out of ukraine
and
noticed that we thought that certain
situations where we could be helpful one
is helping identify
dead russian soldiers or ukrainian
soldiers
and the technology can work on faces
that are deceased
another one is helping
in humanitarian refugee situations to
help verify identity if people don't
have identity cards with them and so we
wrote a letter and i tried every one i
knew in every way possible to get to
someone in the ukrainian government and
they reach back out to us and it's
being used in multiple agencies now and
we've i've gotten a lot of successful
emails coming back saying thank you so
much this is speeding things up in terms
of verifying people
and also it's been used successfully to
id dead russian soldiers and even
find people who claim they're ukrainian
and actually are you know maybe russian
agents there so in this right that
that's i can see that of being
big value yeah claiming to be ukrainian
but they're russian so right there
one takes a picture sends it to them
they look it up they say no that guy's
not a
ukrainian he's russian boom he's playing
the game let's arrest him yeah i mean
that's that's some of the use cases that
uh we laid out in the letter and we've
heard amazing feedback and we're waiting
to hear more of it before we can talk
more about it but it's something that
means a lot to us as a company and to me
personally i help set them up with
accounts and train them and you know
part of our value propositions we do
have about at least two billion photos
from russian social media right uh that
is also publicly
20 billion
you said how many pictures you guys got
about two billion yeah oh got two i know
but total you have how many 20. out of
your 20 billion 2 billion is from russia
yeah so 10 of your images are from
russia yeah what percentage of the 20
billion is from us
i would say most of it is us-based yeah
wow but 10 russia that's massive yeah it
was is one of their you know social
media sites so again that's a use case
we didn't think of when we started but
it's been a great surprise and this is a
situation where things attend so in any
kind of war zone not knowing who someone
is
could lead to some kind of escalation so
it's a technology that allows people to
be more confident to verify you know
someone's identity and it can save lives
and so it's been a great honor there so
we you know go to places where there are
real um issues and able to help them and
we're very you know uh
honored to do that if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]